there's a phone sitting on the desk that
perhaps looks a little old I never had
the first iPhone that came out ten years
ago today June 29th but I did get the
iPhone 3G the next year the original I
didn't really come and the UK to October
and this one came out pretty quickly
afterwards in the next June so yeah just
that we talked about the iPhone and in
fact there's something slightly
different
Chiron is filming this one on my iPhones
are actually shooting this on the iPhone
7 plus give us a way for sure there we
go
excellent we could go into lots of
detail about how the iPhone is the
greatest led by following the trends it
set there's plenty of other people
producing videos that you can get
interviews with people that Apple who
involved in creating it I think the the
fascinating thing for me two things is
purely personal it was a huge difference
when it came out in 2005 I bought this
so as a mobile phone and an iPhone
unfortunately doesn't work anymore if I
drop it into its charging cradle I think
the battery's gone it'll get as far as
booting halfway through the instruction
thing and it'll then just die so I
bought this in 2005 with an iPhone it
was great in some way so it was a
touchscreen with a resistor that you
could tap it and you could use it for
making notes it would run word so yes
just like probably the iPhone is a fact
life is making you turn into a
silhouette and having it here you have
the Ataris is flickering like nobody's
know it's okay I'll just give you a
thought yet so it works ort of quite
well but it had a few 15 it was it
wasn't smooth though it would suddenly
drop the 3G connection or only water eg
a commoner and literally you'd be
sitting there waiting for a phone call
and your phone and completely
disconnected from the network it never
arrived
it was annoying thing and actually see
you could get devices before the iPhone
that did similar features but they just
weren't a swim and actually most of the
time I went back to a sort of classic
Star Trek beam me up Scotty style
motorola pretty soon afterwards and
actually Apple had worked with Motorola
and iTunes compatible very into this the
motorola rokr which was an unmitigated
disaster I think is the phrase it's
perceived this is a phone that we have
worked on with Motorola so actually when
this came along it was in many ways I
think it was just the fact that it just
was so easy to use the sort of
touchscreen the multi chosen zone you
get on it really was revolutionary I
think and of course the influent tau
Android designed their phones and
sorting it sort of changed of course
it's interesting now so for a lot of
people they'll use normal computers they
just use a mobile phone like an iPhone
or an Android phone
perhaps coupled with a tablet like an
iPad as their day to day completely
likely has it's in many ways it's as
much a step from what computers were
like before they are Macintosh to what
they were like after the Macintosh so
before the night no she hadn't liked the
Apple 2 of pcs at the time to the
Macintosh where you had a full sort of
Gilly and we've looked at the Macintosh
couple years ago when it was its 30th
anniversary so you sort of I think it
has created the sea change in the way we
use computers I don't think the vast
majority of people are going to be using
desktop or laptop computers we will
still have them people still using for
certain tasks gaming perhaps although
these Qualcomm consoles may get better
at that who knows phones whatever
certainly development probably want to
do it on that or that I've started get
ideas that are even better on that so
who knows they will just be talking to
computers all the time like in Star Trek
well one thing that I think is also
quite important is it is obviously the
interface it was was revolutionary know
this idea of touch people didn't use to
or didn't have big screens and things
like this yeah I mean it was interesting
the sort of the multi-touch display was
around you could see I think with Jeff
Han had a video that came out early 2006
you have the Microsoft Surface back
where Microsoft Surface made an actual
table service that took up the size of
the room turning friends aren't
music will one day be done with the
greatest of ease the idea was there but
suddenly you went from large displays
than sort of installation type things
it's only fitted in your pocket and I
think that was again how is it having
managed that and actually sort of
realizing the that creating an interface
it was just so usable was sort of
passing the other thing I found a
fascinating thing in terms of its family
tree obvious you've got the Apple sort
of line feeding in it runs Mac effects
or variant of it which comes from the
mag and comes from next and so on but it
was all designed around the ARM chip so
it's actually powered by an ARM chip
which is not unusual with a mobile phone
or the iPod but of course that comes
from the a phone line of things so this
is a hold a con mm and this is the
probably great great great grand
something the granddaddy of the
processor in a modern mobile phone this
was the original arm to chip which power
things like this or the original our
community so I can sort of see a lots of
different lines of Technology sort of
merging to form this one device I would
say one device but that was the one
crystallizing from that you've got the
Android phones your Windows Phone
I'm sure someone still uses them and so
on and it really was different from
having devices with keyboards or limited
interactivity yet you view a web page on
this week II couldn't really do before
even on something like the iPad it
wasn't Apple's first Abbot having some
kind of organize over there so Apple had
in the 90s they created the mutant this
is the original model I didn't have one
at the time I sort of pick one up later
which again you could actually sort of
use to take note it didn't have an
internet connectivity
although I did have an IR port so you
could so stick your mobile phone if you
had an IR port and get online that way
but the interesting thing about this is
that you could actually write on it
and so in the sort of classic let's
create a new note file this note in this
putting business this was sure on trying
it the other day
print note fax beam mail delete that's
probably the best thing logically my
important knows you just absolutely so
in the classic thing we just want to
sort of take a note so in the classic
one we want to beat up Martin and just
like in the symptoms it doesn't come out
with the right answer take a memo on
your new be at Merck so when we actually
got marching this time rather than eat
up Martha
so yeah Apple it didn't actually this
again was probably for its time a
revolutionary device we just wasn't
quite ready the handwriting recognition
wasn't quite good and of course it still
it's Filofax style rather than sort of
slip it in your pocket and use it so
yeah I think everything came together
and we history shown how it's changed
everything running there so yeah and of
course the cameras aren't getting better
and so we can even film computer file on
a mobile phone now so what we got here
it's another biologics dis control of
some sort because I've been protecting
them